welcome to the newshour five weeks into
the war ukraine says russian forces are
withdrawing from the north and areas
around the capital it includes hostimel
that's where russian troops seized an
airport in the first few days of the
invasion now troops are also leaving the
northern city of chernahiv after
shelling it for days
russia has pledged to reduce its
operations in those areas during
negotiations in istanbul taking place
this week and further virtual talks
between the warring sides are set to get
underway in the coming hours now the red
cross is leading an evacuation of
civilians from mario paul on friday but
it's unsure if aid can be delivered
around 160 000 people remain trapped in
the besieged port city with little food
water or a shelter we'll be going live
to hashimoto from moscow in a moment but
first let's bring in rob mcbride who's
joining us from the vive in western
ukraine so ukrainian officials are
saying that russian forces are
withdrawing from several areas
north of kiev how is this withdrawal
being explained rob
that's right we're getting reports from
a number of different locations cities
and towns all between this uh the area
of fighting basically the northern front
uh between kiev and the border with uh
russia the authorities in the capital
akiv say that uh uh some places on the
outskirts of the city such as european
and brovery these are places that have
seen a lot of the intense fighting in
recent weeks the troops russian troops
have been withdrawing their units from
there also august stormell this is the
location of a very important airport
facility and a military facility just to
the northwest of kiev now this was taken
by russian paratroopers you'll remember
the very first day or so of the conflict
it was retaken with a counter-attack by
the ukrainians gradually as the russians
advanced they took this uh airport again
well now footage has emerged on social
media drone footage showing a very uh
deserted airport but very badly damaged
facility but the russians having left uh
from there also from chenoke this is a
city very close to the russian border
the governor of that city says that not
only have russians pull back from the
city but also out of the region as well
he says so it does seem as though the
russians are withdrawing units they said
they would do they said they would be
concentrating on the east of the country
it's difficult to tell exactly what
these units are going to do now they it
does look as though they are they're
being reorganized regrouping replenished
you'll remember some of these units have
actually been out in the field living
under canvas for months they were on
supposed exercises in biella russia and
in russia itself from last november
december so they would be in need of
replenishment of
new recruits joining the ranks have been
regrouping and waiting to see what they
do but of course the fighting's still as
intense in the east of the country and
also down in the south around mariupol
so and speaking of mariopol how are
efforts going to get people out of the
besieged port city
it has been problematic to say the least
to try to get the two sides to agree to
a ceasefire to allow this humanitarian
corridor to be set up they have been
trying now for a couple of days but
according to the international committee
of the red cross the icrc they have the
two sides have agreed just today friday
to set up finally uh this ceasefire to
allow the convoy to get in the
ukrainians have sent down towards the
city now 54 buses which it's hoped will
basically form the the most of the
convoy to
bring aid into the city but also bring
people out many of the thousands who are
desperate to get out the ukrainians also
hope that other private vehicles and
cars will be allowed to join this convoy
to go along the coast of bernanke which
is a city that's
controlled by the russians but then head
north into ukrainian territory but it
remains to be seen just when that will
happen the latest we are getting from
the deputy mayor of mariupol is simply
until now it has simply been too
dangerous for anybody uh to try to leave
the city also accusing the russians in
the last couple of days of stopping even
small amounts of humanitarian aid
getting into into marijuana all right
thank you so much rob mcbride reporting
from levin western ukraine
now the ukrainian president vladimir
zelinsky has warned russia is
consolidating and preparing powerful
strikes in the country's east and south
russian forces have faced tough
resistance in their battle for kakiv the
second biggest city in the country this
report by assad bay contains distressing
images from the start
there's only death here
bodies of young russian soldiers lying
unclaimed
apparent victims of poor tactics
or so the ukrainians tell us
it was very intensive fighting our guys
had high morale a special operation was
planned together with a 90-second
brigade they flanked this position and
then cleared it
the russians had poor defensive
positions save their enemies exposing
them to ukrainian artillery this
was a russian defensive line
all along here
you have what's left over
of this intense battle burnt out tanks
weapons left behind
grenades
they didn't even have time
to take some of their dead
everywhere we look they are signs of
battle
and fear of chemical attack
ukrainian soldiers salvage what's left
the village of mala rohan is back under
ukrainian control but the cost has been
high
a fierce battle pushed the russians away
from the gates of kharkiv
21 year old eugenie has been awarded
ukraine's highest honor for destroying
five tanks and other heroics during
battle
he tells us it's the first time he's
come across the use of phosphorus the
highly flammable chemical phosphorus
it was my first experience with
phosphorus air strikes were not as scary
as the phosphorus
first they used the air strikes then the
phosphorus
my eyes were burning i couldn't breathe
through my nose it was like really
difficult to breathe
the
we can't independently verify its use
this was one of the main streets in this
village
and it's completely destroyed every
building
every window
everything that you see
has some sort of damage there's bullet
holes in the doors the windows have been
blown out there's bricks all over the
place and we've been told that we can
only stick to this main road
because everywhere around hasn't been
completely d mined because the fear is
that the russians have left mines and
booby traps behind for the ukrainian
soldiers taking this place but as you
see
there's not much left
assad beg al-jazeera
outside kharkiv
an oil depot in the russian city of
belgorod on the border with ukraine is
on fire the city's governor says
ukrainian military helicopters attacked
it but keeve has not claimed
responsibility an ammunition depot near
belga road caught fire on wednesday
rania adridi has more from belga road in
russia
previously there were some incidents
where ukrainian shells fell over some
villages in belgorod region but russia
says this is the first time an oil
facility has been targeted
the governor says two ukrainian
helicopters penetrated the russian
airspace without being noticed by the
air defense systems and targeted an oil
tank fires are still blazing at the oil
facility and the russian ministry of
emergency announced that the
firefighting operations are still
ongoing with around 200 fighters using
about 60 special units to fight the
fires all the people in the area have
been evacuated also the russian ministry
of emergency has mentioned that they
fear the fires can spread to eight oil
containers the mayor of belgorod region
denied the news that two people have
been injured and received the necessary
treatment
so firefighting operations are still
going on and so as to prevent any fire
spread to other oil containers and tanks
we'll bring in hashem alberta he's
joining us from moscow to tell us what
officials are saying about that incident
in belgium hashem and also the state of
peace talks
weltering the governor of belgrade is
saying that the the the helicopters
involved in the attacks were flying at
low altitude and they targeted the fuel
depot in berglord which is on the
on the border with the ukraine the
authorities are saying that they are
making all the unnecessary efforts to
ensure there's no disruption of fuel in
the in the area at the same time in the
first reaction the kremlin said that the
attack on back road is not going to be
helpful in the talks with ukraine and as
far as those talks are concerned uh
russian foreign minister sergey lavrov
from india said that
there is a progress in those talks and
that russia is working on a response to
the proposals made by the ukrainians
insisting at the same time that the
ukrainians understand now the status of
both crimea and
dunyas and luhansk as far as crimea is
concerned you remember the ring the
russians have been insisting and one of
the key elements of the deal is for the
ukrainians to recognize crimea as
russian and also recognize both
self-declared republics of lagansk and
dunyas but it remains to be seen how
talks will further evolve particularly
when it comes
to other issues particularly when it
comes to the security arrangements like
ukraine has been asking for something
similar to the nato's collective defense
mechanism and they're both the key
guarantors we'll be playing to in the
future to secure and to
the the security of ukraine lavrov has
also been saying that
the the the west and nato were trying to
use
ukraine as a front to further undermine
the stability in russia and now that
russia is sending a clear message they
cannot tolerate this to happen and this
he says this explains why we're
launching this special operation in the
uk in ukraine and of course hashem the
other big headline is that the deadline
for countries to pay for russian gas in
rubles that deadline is today what's
happening with that
well today the uh russian energy company
gazprom said that he sent messages to
the main suppliers the contractors
asking them to uh to start paying in the
local currency uh the ruble and sergey
lavrov when he was asked about this
particular question about the new rule
which is
has been implemented which asked all the
uh
the supplies to be
accepted in ruble he said that his
country has been attacked economically
by the west and by the americans and
that they have been imposing sanctions
and that it's about time for russia to
create its own mechanisms to protect its
own economy and shield itself from any
further repercussions from the impact of
those sanctions
and he said that this is why we are now
asking all those countries to pay
in in ruble he further elaborated on
what is
widely seen as a russian perspective
when it comes to this whole issue he
said that the u.s in particular wants to
impose a
world order dominated by the u.s where
the euro
where the the dollar and then the euro
are the key currencies
as far as russia is concerned it wants
to also ensure that its local currency
is a key global currency in in global
trade and i think the russians have been
saying so far that they are adamant they
will have to go forward with the need
for all those companies to pay them in
rubble okay thank you so much hashimoto
reporting from moscow we'll continue
this conversation and speak to chris
wiefer who's the chief executive officer
of macro advisory a strategic
consultancy focused on russia and
eurasia joining us from london welcome
to al jazeera so gazprom at the heart of
this but is this more about protecting
it from future sanctions than it is
depriving europe of gas
yeah it's exactly exactly right this is
to some extent is a little bit cosmetic
because the actual procedure that's
changing uh
requires the gas customers in europe to
pay into gazprom bank
in dollars or euros as per the existing
contract and then gazprom bank will
convert that money into rubles for for
onward transmission to to gazprom so the
only change uh that's been made today is
that there's now a new kind of
intermediary bank gazprom bank in the
payment process but for european
customers to still pay in euros and
dollars and the reason russia has done
this
it possibly is a move towards eventually
moving everything to a ruble contract uh
but this is not the case right now this
pretty much ensures that gazprom bank
cannot be sanctioned because of course
the the critical issue for for the
russian economy is that it is able to
not only export key commodities like gas
but also that it can be paid for and can
bring that money back to moscow
therefore it needs at least one big bank
to remain able to use the global swift
payment system um and gazprom bank is is
one of those banks and it now means that
it's pretty much ring fed or
fireproof if you like from being
included in future sanctions because
that would automatically then lead to a
default in the payment system so how
likely is it
how likely is it that european countries
actually pay in rules
no they don't have to pay in rubles they
pay into gas from bank in dollars or
euros and then gas from bank will take
care of the conversion so they do not
this is this is not a move to ruble
payments as such by the customers it
simply puts an intermediary uh bank in
in the system uh that then uh pays
russia in rubles but the customer will
continue to pay in euros or dollars and
that's been confirmed by president putin
and by by uh by both chancellor schultz
and and the italian prime minister who
said that they've had confirmation from
president putin so it is a kind of a
change in the payment system but it is
not moved to rubles uh yet we're a long
way off that we we did hear however
about 24 hours ago from the german
chancellor who called this political
blackmail
well it is to the extent that now uh
europe cannot really sanction gazprom
bank
and therefore they cannot cut russia off
from the global financial system because
if they were to sanction gas from bank
then it means that germany or other
european countries could not pay for
their gas uh and and therefore they
would disrupt the contract and lead to
gas disruption so to that extent it does
raise the stakes
uh and it and it means that you know
europe pretty much has to now kind of
treat gas from banks separately
otherwise they they could run the risk
of gas disruption so it does raise the
stakes but it's it's it is not what we
originally were told which is that
customers would have to pay
rubles into gazprom today that's not the
case they pay their foreign exchange
into gas from bank who then does
conversion for them it makes gas from
bank more important
for the russian payment system and also
for europe's energy security understood
so just on the issue though of gas
disruption i mean there there had been
some speculation up to this point that
um could russia actually turn off the
taps to europe is that likely at this
point
i would say no not at all because
remember russia is just as dependent on
the money it receives for exporting the
gas as the european customers are for
their energy needs so this will be a
mutually destructive move by russia and
there's no indication that russia is
planning that they are certainly playing
clever as it were with regard to the
payment system to try and protect casper
and bank to try and protect uh the one
russian bank in the swift system
but there is no indication whatsoever
that russia is planning on disrupting
export flows uh despite everything
that's happening at a political level
and ukraine russia has been consistently
has been very consistent in this
position that it would always honor
foreign contracts provided the
counterparty does the same so russia
says it will not be the one to break the
contract it is kind of tailoring the
contracts but it said it will never
break it so there's no indication
whatsoever that russia is planning to
cut off any uh energy supplies or other
material supplies to the west so long as
they can get paid for those exports and
just looking at sort of the bigger
picture and the price of crude oil it
has been inflationary over the past
couple of months as you know
uh how do how much pressure do you think
there is on other oil producing nations
uh to turn up their their oil
productions
well clearly there's a lot of pressure
from the consuming countries to to do so
on opec countries in particular but do
bear in mind that the opec plus uh group
has been struggling to actually meet
their production targets anyway they
have not
they took a long time for example to
raise production to the january agreed
levels and since then have been falling
uh well short now of course countries
like saudi arabia and the united
emirates do have spare capacity but they
seem unwilling to move too quickly
because remember they're now making uh
finally making a lot of money uh
running budget surplus
based on the current oil price uh those
countries have been running budget
deficits for years with lower oil price
and only now have sort of moved back
into a budget surplus uh so they're not
willing or they're not willing to
jeopardize that that to add to do
anything that collapse the price uh and
and therefore bring them back into a
budget deficit situation so it's not
surprising therefore that the opec
countries that have capacity are
unwilling to turn that tap on at this
stage we of course have the announcement
from the u.s that they're going to tap
into strategic reserves
and that's can but but really that's not
going to make much difference as you see
in the oil price it's still holding well
above 100 because the strategic reserve
released in the u.s only covers the
amount of oil that the us is now banning
from from russia approximately a million
dollars or so a million barrels a day so
it doesn't really it only covers that
that missing oil it doesn't really add
any extra oil into the global system so
in that sense
yesterday shouldn't disrupt the oil
price and that's what the oil market is
telling you today thank you so much
chris weaver for breaking it all down
for us from london